- [Narrator] Here's another quick tutorial
on how to quickly ruin your life.
Step one, eliminate your goals.
Don't orient yourself
towards a north star,
don't develop a vision for
what your life could be like.
Doing this will make it
impossible to progress in life,
because without a goal, how do
you know you're progressing?
Eliminate any desire to get yourself
out of a suboptimal situation,
subscribe to the idea that
this is just the way life is,
this is all I can be.
It's not hopelessness,
it's self acceptance.
Use loving yourself as an
excuse to spin your wheels
and mentally deteriorate.
Confuse self-love with self-neglect,
wander aimlessly through life
not really knowing why you're here.
Step two, stay inside.
Don't expose yourself to the light,
don't be a person in the world,
stay hidden, operate in the shadows.
Never subject yourself to
the judgment of others,
close yourself off from new information
and new perspectives,
let algorithms create deep grooves
of repeated behavior and topics.
Catering only to your
already limited interests
until you're viewing the same things
and thinking the same thoughts
for the rest of your life.
Allow your mind to shrink
and with it your world.
Step three, avoid risk.
If something's risky, don't do it.
You don't wanna end up like that one guy
who did that thing and lost everything,
what was his name again?
Assume that by avoiding
risk, you get to avoid pain,
believe that the people
who made it big in life
made obvious beneficial decisions
with little perceivable downsides,
and just wait for that
crystal clear opportunity
to come around for you.
Never ask for a raise, tell a risky joke,
or stand up for what you think is right.
Never apply for a job
unless you know for sure
you're gonna get it.
Never ask somebody out
unless you know for certain
that they're interested.
Don't put your hand up
because your question might be stupid.
Always wait for the obvious play
because it'll present
itself eventually, right?
Step four, overthink.
Let every decision you
make no matter how minute
require a deep brooding think.
Assume that your own logic is foolproof.
Get lost in the cobwebs of your own mind,
divorced from external scrutiny.
Develop your own personal
theories about everything
and never bounce these
ideas off other people,
bounce them off yourself.
Step five, consume.
Always consume more than you produce.
Keep your brain entertained at all times,
not by your own creative
endeavors, obviously,
but by other people making stuff.
Fill your mind, not with great
works of art or education,
but with content.
Willingly subject
yourself to the influence
of those who encourage
further consumption.
Constantly stay up to date with reviews,
rumors, comparisons.
Motivate yourself, not
by fostering virtue,
but by accumulating objects,
pay your dues regularly
to remain in this cycle,
and if consumption becomes compulsive,
even better, now you don't
have to think about it.
Step six, avoid criticism.
Don't surround yourself with
people who keep you in check,
challenge your viewpoints,
offer differing perspectives.
Spend time only with those
who think how you think,
act how you act.
Constantly judge those
who live differently,
be quick to shut down any discussion
of matters you're convicted on,
especially ones you're emotional about.
Let your ego blind you
from any real growth,
go through life believing
that you amazingly
have the correct viewpoint on things,
politics, religion, relationships.
Never learn what it feels like
to have your belief system challenged,
because that's uncomfortable.
Step seven, be secretive.
Never expose your darker side
to anyone for any reason,
don't let anybody know about
the bad things you've done
or the things you struggle with.
Let your addictions blossom in secret
where they continue to gain power.
Develop a tendency to hold
your thoughts, actions,
and emotions close to your chest.
Be proactive in maintaining
a facade of perfection.
Never let anyone suspect
that you could have flaws,
or struggles, or any kind
of normal human weakness.
Just focus on the act,
the show must go on,
let what you do in the shadows stay there
rotting you from the inside.
Step eight, avoid conflict.
If something bothers
you, don't mention it.
If someone wrongs you,
tell them it's okay,
we're good, bro.
Never let your disapproval
show on the surface.
Let your resentment
build slowly over time.
Don't correct mistakes as they happen,
pretend not to see them, not to hear them.
After all, talking about
anything uncomfortable
is just not something you wanna do.
You don't want people to
think you're a bad person,
you're nice, and just so
easy to get along with,
at least that's what you
hope people say about you.
Let brief disagreements
remain unaddressed.
Have an elephant in every room.
Let the unsaid fester and grow
evolving gradually into an
overwhelming resentment.
Just try not to snap
because that makes you
look like a bad person,
because it's okay if you slowly start
to hate everyone around you as
long as they don't hate you.
Step nine, play RuneScape.
Step 10, be pessimistic.
Always find a way to put
a negative spin on things,
like a demon on your
shoulder convincing you
that things are worse
than they actually are.
Complain compulsively that
you have to go to work,
instead of that you get to,
lament about all these
things you have to do
as if you're a child being sent to bed.
Get so used to complaining
that you can no longer recognize
when something good happens to you.
Everything is bad,
everything sucks,
cling zealously to
narratives that weaken you
rather than build you up.
Believe that nothing you
ever do will end up working
because you're playing a losing game,
that no habit you try to implement
will ever stick because
they never have before.
Defeat yourself before you even start,
be the demon on your own shoulder,
reflect only on the
negative aspects of yourself
until they're all you can see.
Swaddle yourself in the
despair of inaction,
convince yourself that
that's somehow less painful
than action.
So, if you're generally pretty happy
and you want things to just
seem a little less bright,
then you're in luck, because
if you follow this advice,
you'll probably ruin
the rest of your life.
A big thank you to Athletic Greens
for sponsoring this video.
You guys already know that
AG1 is my favorite supplement,
and that's because there's
basically no competing
with how easy and simple it is to drink,
as well as how good it is for you
and how good it makes me
feel throughout the day.
Packed with over 75 vitamins, minerals,
whole food-sourced super foods,
and adaptogens in every single scoop,
AG1 gives your body everything it needs
to help you feel focused and
energized throughout the day.
And unlike so many basic multivitamins,
AG1 has a high degree of bio availability,
which means that your body
can actually absorb it
so it can use it in the
most effective way possible.
So if you're interested in joining me
in this simple daily habit
that I've been doing
for about two years now,
then if you use my link
in the description below,
you'll also get a year's supply
of the Vitamin D3 and K2 Complex,
which I also have every single morning,
as well as five AG1 travel
packs with your first purchase.
So, click that link to take
advantage of that amazing offer,
and thanks again to Athletic Greens
for sponsoring this video.
These types of anti
tutorials are kind of a way
to bring these darker
aspects of our psyche
and our behaviors into the light
rather than keeping them in secret
and not talking about them.
It helps me reflect on my
own negative tendencies
so that I can recognize
how silly they are.
So if you found this helpful,
I would appreciate it if
you hit the like button
which will also help other
people see this video
and hopefully it'll help them recognize
their own negative thought
patterns and behaviors.
If you are lurking here
and you've seen a bunch
of my videos before
or if this is the first one,
consider hitting the subscribe button.
But other than that, thank
you so much for watching
and we'll catch you in the next video.